[Musica]
oggi parliamo di futuro e vista l'ora io
parlerò di futuro del cibo e quanto è
facile fare previsioni su quello che
accadrà al mondo del cibo è molto
difficile direi che finora abbiamo
sbagliato quasi sempre quando quando ero
bambino io faccio parte della
generazione dei baby boom per cui nei
primi anni sessanta
cercavo di immaginare come sarebbe stato
il futuro del cibo il futuro per chi è
della mia generazione era il 2000 se vi
ricordate il 2000 era l'anno in cui
tutto sarebbe cambiato e come immaginavo
il cibo del 2000 quando ero bambino e
come lo immaginavano le persone
all'epoca un cibo molto poco attraente
pillole poltiglie freni né cose da
assumere in maniera così completa per la
nutrizione ma certamente non qualcosa di
edonistico e non ero solo naturalmente a
pensarlo se ci pensate
c'era anche tutta una epopea di
fantascienza
questo è un film che tutti sicuramente
avete visto guardate come loro pensavano
che avremmo mangiato nel 2001 e guardate
quanto la previsione è stata sbagliata
in realtà qualcosa di giusto
nell'immagine la vedete 1968 quando uscì
questo fin guardate l'ipad è incredibile
era esattamente come oggi l'unica cosa
che stanley kubrick e non aveva
immaginato e real touchscreen infatti
c'è ancora i piccoli tastini però questa
è questa la dea azzeccata il cibo 9 era
forse anche azzeccato un altra
previsione che avremmo dato molta
importanza nel cibo ad alcuni alimenti
qui vedete legumi verdura pesce non si
vede pasta non si vedono cose che oggi
carne che forse oggi i dietisti
consigliano di mangiare con million con
maggiore moderazione
e poi c'era un'altra previsione
sbagliata questa è divertente
pan am panamera la linea aerea più
importante dell'epoca realtà è fallita
pochi anni dopo il film
altra previsione altra previsione errata
è il cibo oggi dopo il 2000 molto
diverso molto diverso
c'è molta attenzione all'esperienza
direi che siamo molto più attenti alla
cucina la qualità del cibo alla bontà
degli alimenti di quanto non pensavamo
saremmo stati all'epoca e addirittura se
oggi chiedete a un bambino cosa vuole
fare da grande la nostra generazione
avrebbe detto forse l'esploratore
avrebbe detto il maiale dell'astronauta
oggi il 63 per cento dei millennials
vogliono fare gli chef quindi c'è
un'attenzione direi esasperata alla
qualità del cibo e tutti i suoi aspetti
più piacevoli altro che poltiglie
pillole e altri altri prodotti altri
prodotti chimici tra l'altro della
generazione millennials quella che è
nata proprio alla fine del secolo scorso
fanno parte anche le mie due figlie e mi
sono chiesto ma loro che tipo di
previsioni facevano quando erano bambini
e rispetto al futuro magari facendosi
condizionare dei film dell'epoca
questo era wallin che è uscito quando lo
erano bambine e la preoccupazione che
poteva nascere a forse mangeremo troppo
c'è talmente tanto cibo sono talmente
tante cose buone junk food fast food che
probabilmente saremo tutti troppo grassi
questa è una previsione azzeccata
oddio in parte sì questi sono i dati o
eccidi su il peso e quindi il sovrappeso
dei ragazzi tra i 5 e 17 anni quindi i
giovani e purtroppo siamo messi
abbastanza male se non ci fosse la
grecia che spesso ci salva dall ultimo
posto in classifica siamo
secondi siamo i secondi
addirittura gli stati uniti che noi
abbiamo sempre accusato e pensiamo che
nel nostro immaginario siano il popolo
che mangia forse in maniera squilibrato
eccessiva in realtà stanno meglio di noi
sono sono al quinto posto quindi
qualcosa effettivamente è successo però
possiamo dire che questa previsione
corretta io non credo perché in realtà
allo stesso tempo sta aumentando
enormemente l'interesse delle persone a
raggiungere il peso giusto
pensate soltanto alla quantità di diete
che oggi sono di in voga e quanta
attenzione noi molti di noi pongono a
quello che si mangia
ho citato e penso ai vegetariani
pensiamo ai vegani di pesce italiani
forse non li conoscete ma sono gli
italiani che mangiano anche il pesce i
pali o dietisti che mangiano quello che
si mangia a 15 mila anni fa con l'idea
che all'epoca non si era grassi quindi
probabilmente conviene fare come
facevano allora i crudisti che non
vogliono cucinare vogliono mangiare i
cibi crudi i fruttariani solo frutta
steve jobs tra l'altro era uno di loro
non è affatto una vice lunghissima però
il fruttariani sono un'altra sicuramente
dieta attenta a cosa sa cosa si prenda
addirittura il più incredibile sono i
respiri anni che forse avete visto dei
servizi in televisione sono quelli che
praticamente pensano che sia sufficiente
respirare e mangiare il minimo possibile
quindi io credo ha tra l'altro c'è
un'altra categoria che mi diverte molto
i mégane ii mangiano di tutto ma si
rifiutano di ammetterlo questo non so se
se qualcuno di voi ne fa parte ma
sicuramente sono più numerosi di quanto
pensiamo e poi c'è attenzione all'altra
forma importante di attenzione al al
fisico quindi ci stiamo muovendo di più
devo dire che almeno quelli della mia
generazione sono ossessionati da correre
muoversi per ridurre il cibo e anche i
bambini per fortuna
pensate questa è la la campagna che ha
lanciato lancio michelle obama sul prato
adesso c'è qualcun altro e per far
muovere i bambini che in effetti si era
scoperto che non era tanto e non solo
una questione di cibo ma i bambini che
si muovono assolutamente troppo poco
rispetto a quello che dovrebbero
rispetto naturalmente anche le
generazioni precedenti che stavano
sempre per strada a loro stanno troppo
davanti al computer tra l'altro la
generazione z quella che vedete qui
saltellare cioè quelli che sono nati
dopo il 2000 fa parte anche un mio terzo
figlio
mi sono domandato ma uno della
generazione z pensa al futuro del cibo
come si immagina che potrebbe cosa si
immagina potrebbe accadere magari
guardando anche in questo caso dei film
di fantascienza
questo è un film che è uscito da poco
interstellar forse l'avete visto lila la
previsione abbastanza catastrofica si
dice che il futuro del cibo e il non
cibo non cibo a sufficienza per tutti
come forse sapete le previsioni sono
abbastanza allarmanti sull'incremento
demografico saremo nel 2050 saremo 10
miliardi quindi la prima reazione di chi
fa previsioni sul cibo dire non basterà
il cibo questa però vi posso
tranquillizzare non è anche questa una
previsione del tutto corretta per almeno
due motivi molto seri il primo qui non
leggete i numeri ma ve lo racconto è
quanto cibo si produce pensate la curva
in alto e la curva della popolazione che
aumenta anche se pare sia un pochino
interrompendo la sua crescita
la curva sotto invece è quella delle
calorie e medie pro capite prodotte nel
mondo quindi non solo sono in linea con
la crescita ma addirittura cresce quindi
c'è più calorie pro capite man mano che
passano passano gli anni e poi c'è una
seconda motivazione direi che questa è è
ancora più incredibile è che noi
sprechiamo più del 30 per cento di
quello che produciamo per cui dire che
non basterà il cibo in realtà è una
ipotesi
talmente errata ne sprechiamo
praticamente un terzo in più nei
continuiamo a produrre sempre di più
quindi la versione potrebbe essere molto
più positiva del previsto quindi
potremmo concludere che va tutto bene
che quindi sul cibo non avremo di
qualità né mangeremo il giusto e ce ne
sarà per tutti
sì però un problema in realtà c'è un
problema di cui si parla molto poco di
cui neanche film di fantascienza parlano
ma invece il vero problema dei problemi
che il riscaldamento globale scaldamento
globale sapete cosa vuol dire la
produzione di co2 nostra è talmente
enorme che si sta riscaldando il pianeta
riscaldare il pianeta vuol dire togliere
i ghiacciai vuol dire fenomeni naturali
estremi vuol dire alluvioni vuol dire la
fine anche le stesse migrazioni che
sappiamo che tipo di problemi stanno
creando al mondo e la co2 quindi
riscaldamento globale è generato da tre
fondamentali cause la prima la
produzione di energia ai processi
industriali e questo per tutti ovvio la
seconda sono i trasporti lo sappiamo
ogni volta che ci muoviamo con una
macchina un aereo produciamo co2
la terza che è molto meno conosciuta ma
riguarda un terzo delle emissioni è
proprio l'agricoltura per cui in realtà
ciò che mangiamo sta producendo un terzo
dei nostri problemi il modo in cui li
produciamo il cibo sta inaridendo il
nostro il nostro pianeta quindi sempre
facendosi al film di fantascienza se
vogliamo evitare di mangiare patate
coltivate coi nostri rifiuti e quindi
stare una situazione tipo quella di
marte
questo era il film che lo ipotizzava
dobbiamo fare attenzione a come
comportarci bene per produrre sì ma in
maniera sostenibile dal punto di vista
ambientale una preoccupazione che è
molto poco condivisa dalle persone
c'è una buona notizia in tutto questo se
noi mangiamo correttamente la dieta
mediterranea è considerata sicuramente
una delle diete migliori quindi poca
carne molta frutta verdura pasta pane e
quant'altro abbiamo anche l'impatto
minore quindi la piramide che vedete
sulla destra e l'impatto delle singole
categorie di cibo che vedete che
decresce man mano che andiamo verso i
cibi che dovremmo mangiare più mangiare
più spesso quindi questa è una buona
notizia
la cattiva notizia che siamo
effettivamente talmente tanti che anche
se produciamo il cibo
in maniera corretta però di fatto
l'impatto è molto molto elevato quindi
quali sono le possibili soluzioni e mi
avvio la conclusione la prima soluzione
che spesso viene proposta dalle grandi
aziende sostanzialmente è una soluzione
molto basata sull'innovazione
tecnologica legata alla genetica
quindi pensiamo al tema degli ogm
pensiamo alla chimica quella che è stata
chiamata rivoluzione verde che
sostanzialmente è stata un'agricoltura
molto intensiva ma molto anche diciamo
forse il più vicino alla chimica che non
alle nostre tradizioni ed è un estremo
contestato ma comunque chiaramente ha
portato avanti da da da diversi gruppi
di interesse la seconda è l'estremo no
dimentichiamo tutto km zero orto sotto
casa mangiamo quello che produciamo
ritorniamo completamente al passato dice
che dire che per vari motivi
nessuna di queste due soluzioni può
essere sostenibile la prima perché in
effetti peggiora la situazione dei
terreni e la seconda perché comunque con
10 miliardi di persone sono sicuri si
produce il suo cibo l'economia di scala
non esistono e si ottiene addirittura si
potrebbe ottenere l'effetto contrario
quindi la soluzione quale dovrebbe
essere equi
la mia proposta la soluzione dovrebbe
essere qualcosa che mette insieme questi
due mondi
quindi da un lato del passato dobbiamo
trarre i veri valori che abbiamo
dimenticato primo tra tutti il valore
del cibo
quanto deve costare qual è il suo giusto
prezzo quindi attenzione al cibo come
prodotto necessario per noi ma anche
ideologicamente di qua di importante la
seconda la seconda mondo quello della
dell'innovazione deve aiutare a
utilizzare i principi del passato quindi
oltre all'importanza del cibo anche la
biodiversità anche il fatto che i campi
devono essere utilizzati in maniera
naturale quindi attraverso le rotazioni
ma attraverso la tecnologia che lo rende
più efficienti per uscire da questo
diciamo situazione che può sembrare un
po confusa ho parlato di retro
innovazione quindi innovazione si ma con
i valori del passato e voglio portare un
esempio
questa è una start up nata dall
università di piacenza che ha approvato
sul grano duro che esattamente quello
che viene utilizzato per la pasta a
mettere insieme questi due principi
quindi grande attenzione alla
biodiversità
stazioni nei campi un tipo di
coltivazione molto rispettosa della
natura ma allo stesso tempo tanta
tecnologia sistemi esperti i modelli di
supporto alle decisioni per gli
agricoltori sensori satelliti che dicono
quando irrigare quando fare certe
attività quando evitare che sia soltanto
l'istinto e l'intuito del coltivatore a
guidare tutto il processo produttivo
come è successo bene con questo
esperimento fatto su molti campi in
italia si è ridotto il carbon footprint
prodotto quindi la produzione co2
prodotta da quei campi sono ridotti
addirittura i costi per gli agricoltori
perché c'è voluto il bisogno di meno per
esempio fertilizzanti e terzo sia
aumentato il reddito quindi sono
realizzate delle cose in genere così se
considerate contrastanti cioè ridurre
l'impatto aumentare le rese e dare un
prodotto di qualità non è fantascienza
per chi fosse interessato sono molti
documenti che raccontano come ha
funzionato questo l'elemento forse più
interessante che c'è un innovazione
anche dal punto di vista contrattuale
nel senso che l'agricoltore viene
garantito per quello che produce sul
campo anche se cambiasse di anno in anno
la produzione come la sostenibilità
richiederebbe troppo mettendo insieme
aziende diverse aziende che producono
passata di pomodoro piuttosto che
piselli basilico grano e quindi dare la
possibilità agli agricoltori di
alternare in maniera corretta senza che
per loro però ci sia il rischio di non
vendere nell'anno in cui fanno un
prodotto che magari è meno richiesto dal
mercato come si riesce a realizzare
questa retro innovazione collaborazione
apertura esattamente quello che è stato
detto da molti relatori prima di me cioè
fare in modo che piccole aziende
collaborino con grandi aziende e la
start up di cui dicevo prima è riuscita
a realizzare questo per un accordo col
più grande produttore di pasta al mondo
occorre che i giovani che hanno meno
condizionamenti psicologici possano
inter intervenire nelle decisioni e
portare soluzioni innovative e quindi
tutto il mondo delle startup e direi un
atteggiamento complessivamente meno
disciplinare meno specialistico ma più
aperto e multiculturale
multidisciplinare funziona l'abbiamo
provato
la mia domanda la domanda che mi sono
fatto è questo tipo di approccio può
vedere nel italia anche un paese guida
io penso di sì perché l'italia in
passato e forse anche roma hanno già
dimostrato di poter guidare dei
cambiamenti importanti
[Applauso]